sometimes watching a movie isn't enough
you also want to eat that movie and
that's why there's movie recipes today
we're going to show you how to make
Christmas Story - eggnog
start off by finding the most classic
and beloved Christmas treat you can
imagine and for only a drop of it into
your blender because even though it was
perfect the way it was we need to
needlessly update it despite the fact
that nobody asked us to next you'll want
to put in a vegan hot dog because
clearly there's no meat to this product
whatsoever after that you want to find a
drumstick that's been needlessly used
for slapping renditions of classics
often contain a lot of unnecessary
slapstick what's that you didn't laugh
at that joke well then clearly we're
making the right recipe naturally you're
going to need stars look deep into the
back of your fridge for the leftover
star fruit that's expired way past its
prime it has an aged well and you
probably forgot it even existed but it's
cheap and available and that's all that
really matters
finally water it down as much as you can
so you can't even recognize what it was
originally trying to replicate in the
first place
blend whatever charm it had left into a
creamy liquid ready to be pointlessly
forced down your throat be sure it's
poured into a glass that looks festive
and tasteful deceiving you into what
you're about to subject yourself to
finally garnish with a lit cigarette and
enjoy well what other reaction would
you've expected
welcome to earth
I'll trade you this cigarette butt for
your coat oh my god it must be my
birthday hey sucker
you
apologies my psychotic kind
ex-girlfriend just landed after being
blown up by a PlayStation 3 that wasn't
even plugged in it's a long story anyway
I have worse taste to wash out of my
mouth for example why the hell have we
been trying to kill a Christmas story
the past 10 years
remember what used to be that little
film that not too many people knew about
so you kinda shared it in the hopes that
get more attention and then it's somehow
ridiculously backfired to a point where
now it gets too much fucking attention
is a goddamn enterprise I suppose in
many respects this is expected but by
god they just market it in the most
obnoxious way there's never a sense that
the advertisers are doing this because
they like the movie it's so obvious
they're doing it because it's popular
and we'll make a quick buck one
motorless c13 no with texts and games
and graphics still run the bill up kid
Oh even if that is the reason behind it
you're not supposed to be so lazily
blamed about it this is where Christmas
Story 2 comes in nowhere else will you
find the needless desperate
money-grubbing whore element of
Christmas then with the very idea of
this film it's such a horrible thought
that even the trailer got probably the
biggest amount of downloads I've seen in
a while
I don't think Hitler could come back
from the grave and get as many down
votes if people say Christmas has gone
commercial and lost its soul this is the
product to prove they're right because
yeah 30 years later we just demanded
that the rest of the Christmas story
saga be told we just couldn't sleep
until that obvious cliffhanger ending
was addressed it just makes me realize
how much Christmas has become glorifying
buying a bunch of bullshit that we don't
actually need what's next it's a
Wonderful Life - a Christmas carol - the
Star Wars Holiday Special - when I get
Ad I swear this special is so bad that
not only hasn't put me off of the
original story but it may have put me
off of Christmas all together
hello hi Benny a type of fangirl how are
you not well just found out that
clueless is a fucking ripoff well I need
your help I finally know what to do to
the Nostalgia Critic ah don't you ever
learn your frigging lesson no and 20
grand says neither do you
I'll be there in 10 minutes you don't
know where I am I know where everyone is
so with the ceremonial swearing of a
channel awesome producer who's already
viewed this may read mutha fucking
Christmas you got this is Christmas
story too we open with what I know
you've seen an abundance of in the first
film CGI backdrops oh it's like I'm back
in the 40s already to the film's credit
they do try to sepia tone it so that it
looks a bit more like the first film but
it comes out like the Lifetime network
and the Hallmark Channel took a piss on
the same- a few winners had passed in
yet another when it comes screaming over
Lake Michigan in the middle of the night
the narrator is voiced by the writer of
this shitstain and though doing a decent
mimic of the original author his shaky
voice sounds like he's saying these
lines with a gun to his head Randy was a
fledgling Buck Rogers fanatic who had
his own way of braving life's little
conflicts in this world or any other
they forced me to write this or they
take away my other testicle I mean it
was a beautiful day in Indiana and there
I am with that same dumb round face and
the same penetrating 2090 vision yes the
more we say the words saying the more we
hope it'll mentally brainwash you into
thinking that they actually are the same
they're not of course as we see the
father is now played by Daniel Stern
portraying him as an overcooked Rodney
Dangerfield I'm telling you boys if I on
that team things would be a whole lot
different great another role I can do
with bug-eyes is speaking on the side of
my mouth do the actors credit the
Kipling Ralphie actually does a decent
job he captures the spirit of the
original performer but
Maja's to make it his own the rest well
remember that bad community college play
you had to watch a long time ago let
this joker cut in its dog eat dog out
here stake your claim in son of a bitch
this is how I really am I swear I'm not
playing a character good son of a bitch
catchphrase but of course maybe I like
Ralph he's acting in this because he
barely gets a fucking line practically
90% of his dialogue is the voice-over
narration and it never shuts up the old
man maintained his well-deserved status
the old man lived for the thrill of the
hunt the old man's scheme was always the
same the old man remained positive and
his encouragement the old man was a
veritable cliche repository as the old
man would say why don't you just marry
the fucking old man Jesus Christ the
audio book has left narration than this
we don't need every single moment of
life explained to us guy then I open the
fridge
Iowa confused because I heard a strange
voice then I close the fridge because if
not the cold will get out
I then drank my soda and began walking
back I started with the left foot then
proceeded with the right point then
proceeded with the led point then
proceeded with the right foot
Drusilla goo tread my sweet true Scylla
now look the only character in the movie
to have less lines than Ralphie the
out-of-place millennial girlfriend who
you of course want to see get with
Ralphie because well she's hot and
doesn't say anything and apparently
those were great qualities in the boys
the rest of us would have to settle for
being with her in our dreams
oh hey daydreaming because first movie I
could help to refresh your memory
that's a weird addition to have in your
fantasy if I closed have the perverted
Ralphie counter on the side I just get
the feeling we're gonna need it
throughout this film Shelley you saved
me from a fate worse than death
no no you're still in the movie honey
did one of the subplots in this film is
that Ralphie and his old man
are looking to buy a used cock Ralphie
sees the car he wants and has he had
another fantasy where he's a blood elf
Franken and sneaks an ad for what he
wants in the paper because like I said
first movie speaking of which guess what
after all these years still isn't fixed
so wait they can afford another car but
not a new furnace well I guess it does
give us a barrel of laughs that clearly
is never opened
meanwhile Ralphie fetishizes more at
school about his millennial girlfriend
and just tell me he doesn't up the
creepiness in this scene for 45 minutes
twice a week Drusilla and I could be
together close enough to smell her
lavender scented shampoo
oh yeah that's definitely going on the
counter someday my beauty there'll be a
veil upon that hair and I'll lift it so
our lips can meet as they pronounce this
man and wife Jesus Christ kid perfume or
on there that I was really fucked up a
little less holiday spirit mr. Parker
and change your pants from the top
people
hmm you know I wonder what was poking me
at the back of my head oh my god so
Raffy sees that his car might be bought
by another buyer so in a room that I'm
sure invites no negative repercussions
whatsoever Ralphie gets inside the car
so he can go through those negative
repercussions I'm sure he won't go
through
you know I think there's other ways
around this Ralphy rather than taking
off your pants
so they destroy the car and the owner
says he has to pay him back $85 to fix
it which back then is like I don't know
a billion bucks or something
this of course calls for $1 thinking
fantasy it was for absolution my son
dead kid walking you know when his
daydreaming have grown up a bit I mean
he's a teenager but he still dreams like
he's a ten-year-old boy it makes no
sense gee let me think about where I'm
gonna fake a Shinto next year maybe I
can eat the taxi driver so he tries to
ask his father about getting the money
you need a little extra dough for
Christmas right why don't you get
something nice for your mother I'll give
you a buck give you two huh
could I have any three more why oh sorry
I supposed to be funny helpers has been
replaced with soothing hiccuping and
constipation grunts it may not make you
laugh but I'm Daniel Stern I'm used to
it it's Christmas right
babies will hire anybody on Christmas
we'll go tomorrow so he gets an idea to
get a job at the local department store
I'd be the kind of part-time holiday
help that legends are made of by fellow
Americans oh my god stop with the
fantasies simple scrubs and Family Guy
have less cutaways than you
I still know nothing about you that the
audience is supposed to support my
shallowness for some reason and it
doesn't stop there
there's still like a million more
fucking fantasies throughout the rest of
this film could someone just pooping out
my misery and shoot me in the head I've
got on my site all right time to show
you the true meaning of Christmas
you
today our person this might seem strange
hi critic we heard that you were getting
the blues about Christmas so we decided
to show you why you originally loved one
of your favorite holiday classics the
wanton mother so wearing the constant
anger it's really creepy Santa is for
sharing for scaring your kids please say
your Chinese singing that offends you
that man we know you'd you're talk - I
don't think it worked
this must be a really bad movie come on
come on come on then go to get a turkey
for Christmas but Papa's not happy that
the price has gone up but thankfully
that some real comedy is ready to start
as Ralphie in the gang get ready to
begin their jobs but hey near infant
suffocation is understandable in
anybody's first day that's why they
don't get fired and instead just
transfer to different parts of the store
observe excuse me miss care to sample
our new fragrance
you can manage that now I expected these
banana cream pies not to be torched by
the end of the evening and of course
this results in low Jake's which is kind
of like high jinks just not trying as
hard
that wasn't we sound effect folks we are
desperate enough to put in a we sound
effect oh oh oh clearly someone's been
learning from the Masters naturally even
these fuck-ups aren't enough to get them
fired what do you have to do skip a
patron as they're given yet another
wacky job to partake it just stamp both
copies file the yellow one in the tray
and send the pink one you think you can
handle that but flick just finds it's
too tempting not to put his tongue
inside the pipe because again there's
your holiday image folks a prosthetic
version of Pike cunnilingus and a Happy
New Year after that they have to stand
in as elves for a really mean-spirited
Santa Clause because doctors 800 oh my
god I remember that I remember that hey
come sucks
Oh Oh alright what's your story what do
you want how about a new pair of gloves
that disappeared in between shots yeah
get off your Lord as you make some money
yeah so she can spend it on punch boards
a cheap gin it's weird because the Santa
here is a lot more mean than in the last
one but of course because this door
seems anti-progress they decide not to
fire him and get a new one this results
in what I suppose is supposed to be
Ralphie standing up for Christmas you
can all go home
Shanta for you he is not worth but
naturally it's just 1/4 segue into hey
whatever the hell this is bullshit
haven't you heard this place is like a
cult once you go in you can never
fucking get out you have to get a
blowjob by the decapitated head of one
of the customers in order to finally get
kicked out of this place oh I need a
drink thank you how are you gonna get
out of here Benny don't worry all I need
is a bobby pin and the complete works of
Lewis Carroll Thanks yeah no problem
meanwhile the father tries to go fishing
on fake CGI Bird Lake as he plans to
make fish this year's Christmas feast
seeing how it's cheaper even though the
gas money driving out there repeatedly
is probably costing him more than the
damn turkey would look like there pull
this yeah too many then make that hole
for a fish that was supposed to be big
enough to feed your family just a tiny
bit fucking bigger oh maybe it cost more
money they lose the fish which results
in big shock but bother being a total
dick again sorry just trying to help
haven't you done enough of that already
you know I'm not quite sure what you
mean that means that you changed it
that's what it means it means that
everything was going great till you
showed up you know the father in the
first film was tough and had his flaws
but he's still very likable this guy is
just a complete asshole from beginning
to end
what's his encore singing great balls of
fire at the burn ward our own employment
picture grew significantly dimmer that
evening when I lost the first and only
job I'd ever
hey there is such a thing as Christmas
miracles I knew I'd probably never
experienced a Christmas quite like this
one
and I wasn't alone my mother realized
that in a sense she too was about to be
relieved of a job that one day soon it
would be time to let go of her son is
that what we were supposed to be taking
out of this I think this is the first
time it's being addressed
it's like saying the main focus of a
lien was supposed to be the cat I don't
think you have the attention in the
right spot Ralphie has a talk with his
father because apparently seeing a grown
man bicha moan like a whiny brat against
the flattest forests in the world can't
help but open a guy up you know what
they say sometimes it's the last key in
the bunch it opens the lock I know just
what that means
good so with his newly found fortune
cookie philosophy he goes back to the
store to ask for his old job back and
what does he do with his all too
important second chance try to fuck it
up of course
what the fuck am i watching right now no
I legitimately have no idea he's having
a spasm attack because this weird
Gestapo guy isn't ringing the bell right
so much for learning any responsibility
what a deer bag lousy caught tail klutz
sorry I'll pick it up
sir that five guy in the corners
flunking money I don't know what you're
talking about
actually you do wait he punched him in
the gut yet he's giving his money back
that's the kindest abuser of teenagers
and reindeer suits I've ever seen and to
be fair I've seen a couple as he's
counting the money he sees he's still
one dollar short
I just need a dollar one lousy dollar
what's in the pocket Schwartz that's not
funny
number one you can't have my lucky buck
okay I'm sorry I have questions
what $1 worth more that is now but I
think it's still possible to get one
he'll even his cheapskate father was
offering him one too why the hell are
they taking off his pants there's
literally no reason for it free it still
Ralphie's problem so why the hell are
they stealing from him it's not like
this other kid played any part of
ruining the car nothing like a little
Christmas theft to get in the giving
mood Christmas give me the fuckin
morning so he wants to pay off the
dealer while walking by one of those leg
lamps because don't bother when he sees
a poor family in the alley looks like a
white Christmas tomorrow well that's the
way it should be right yes sir it is
Merry Christmas and go forgive us for
being in this film everyone so he
decides to take the money he was going
to pay the car dealer and take the poor
family out for dinner instead well I'm
sure glad being pot raped in a jail cell
isn't as important as getting food to a
family that obviously was finding ways
to eat already and don't get me wrong I
know it's good to give over the holidays
it makes a lot of sense but for the love
of God if you're going to jail fucking
jail I think the poor would understand
if you gotta use that money to pay
something off but to keep your ass out
of jail I mean that's not being greedy
that's just surviving that's just being
a human being trying to tell me cuz we
all had to triple dog dare how the
hell'd you get out my office I just made
an extra door with what I had lying
around
what are you adoring Christmas as you
should be we just don't want you to lose
the holiday spirit critic I swear if I
see your face again I will lose your
head in a car filled okay that was
really dark and I don't condone that
kind of behavior but nevertheless the
pants off he goes to the dealer telling
him what he's done and of course the
dealer doesn't care skip it you're done
I am yeah merry ho ho and all that you
know spirit of the season so I guess the
more of the story is a bailout is bad
unless the guy in charge of the bailout
is bailing you out
sounds like a corporate America listen
to me apparently he's not the only one
who gets bailed out the mother used the
money she was saving up on the side to
buy a fish claiming that their father
caught it look at the dinner your father
caught just for us my brother never
heard what really happened it hasn't to
this day I just pray he never sees this
movie Oh Who am I kidding
nobody will
they wake up the next morning to look at
all the boxes we clearly nothing in them
and they have I suppose a merry enough
Christmas thank you thank you
I told you'd like it you wanted to get
him socks well last time I save your ass
handing over my life savings for a
fucking carp my god what a terrible
human being you guys get everything you
wanted don't say so I think I just saw a
rat in the kitchen isn't it beautiful
so Ralphie apparently got his old man
the lamp guess he spent part of his
don't go to jail money on that and his
father rewards him with what else the
car he always wanted you know for family
they've been building up as financially
struggling they do get each other some
fucking nice gifts don't they this of
course catches the eye of our millennial
you should really leave the car oh we
should have talked I'm sorry I just
assumed you'd communicate through
blinking or something do you remember
the other day in front of Higbee's
antlers sleigh bells uh yeah
I'm just gonna act out the trope like
I'm embarrassed and you're not gonna
like me for that even though you
obviously are looks a lot of guts to
stand up to a jerk like that
and they all died in a terrible car
accident very shortly after oh my god
which is why the original is so much
better policy we wanted to try yeah
two minutes give me a second good job Oh
the vultures we wanted to try actually
what the tax Ralphie's telling such a
big life ciao ciao ciao ciao
ah seriously
what the fuck is wrong with you do you
honestly think these actions are gonna
win me over I did no no no no no no no
you break into my home you kidnap me you
stalk me I found out the fucking Jupiter
with you I was just trying to get you
back into the Christmas spirit by making
like Christmas Story again I love
Christmas I love Christmas Story ah it's
you I can't stand I mean I swear my life
will be so much happier if you would
just disappear from it wait wait wait
wait wait wait what are you trying to
say
I hate you I hate everything about you
if there was a likeability scale between
one and ten you be negative PI you for
now more than 28 states just so people
don't have to talk to you again if they
were to make a clone of you and be
called essence of annoying if kids are
got cancer you would be the one they
would name it after knock knock who's
there nobody because nobody would ever
want to see you when people ask most
what the meaning of life is they say
stay away from your dumb ass you're
Beethoven's lost Symphony that's to Joy
what everyone in the noisewater brown
hair glasses and a likeable personality
please raise their hand you just stupid
even get that joke on the evolutionary
scale you're the only one that's walking
backwards to the surgeon general's
warning I'm not we pack of cigarettes
give me an I give me an H th e yo hi hi
okay critic that's how you're you wait
what what what are you doing mmm I'm
just gonna go within wait that you can't
do that it's it's cheating
this wasn't how played out in my head
you
I don't see the Christ are you here well
I heard somebody was trying to make a
Christmas Story - eggnog and I thought
well I'd give it a whirl Wow
it was a bad idea Santa Christ I need
your help on something I just threw out
this really annoying person named Piper
fangirl whoa what did she do she tried
to make me appreciate Christmas wow
you're a douche no no it's not like that
though she did all these terrible things
and she deserves to be punished for it
last I heard she was flying 30,000 feet
through the air completely set on fire
sounds like punishment enough to me
you're not gonna be on my side are you I
don't think you're on your side this
dumbass movie
you fill me with so much hate this
Christmas I forgot about the things that
really are great Christmas story is
overplayed and over commercialized and
yes it's ironic that a film based in
simple truths in a small town
environment would be blown up into this
marketing monster of kitsch with this
piece-of-shit sequel being the crown of
it but that doesn't mean what was
already good and simple can't remain
good and simple
hell if looked at the right way this
sequel can show why the original is so
unique and innocent by comparing it to
its bastard cousin that's cliched and
corrupted in all its complex marketing I
can see once again that simple
appreciation I don't think I was seen
that if it wasn't for another simple
Santa Christ can you grant me a
Christmas wish
sure I'm Santa Christ I need you to take
me back before I start this review
absolutely heck it saved me from this
terrible eggnog
Hey
you know what you do was wrong right
and you know that this isn't gonna work
right
look um I was gonna put on a really bad
Christmas special you want to make fun
of it with me
you
and I'm married to mrs. Christ Oh
seriously 20 guesses who it is The Da
Vinci Code got it wrong I think you'll
be pleasantly surprised
I wish I wasn't such a softie